we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 David P take a listen to this
voicemail about
Mayo brains
David Jeremy in Oregon here uh I love
your analogy to these people's brains
and mayonnaise because for one
mayonnaise is gross and uh so I actually
I actually like Mayo I think Mayo is
great yeah I love the pronunciation and
I didn't have another example of why but
yeah it's gross and that's a good
example yeah I didn't come up I mean to
be honest I know some people think that
I call people Mayo brained because I
think mayonnaise is gross I actually
love mayonnaise and I didn't come up
with it Mayo brained is just a known
term you can check it out on Urban
Dictionary you can check it out
elsewhere I wish I could take credit for
that I really do but I genuinely cannot
we have such a great bonus show for you
today that I think even Alex Jones is
gonna go for this one thank you lucky
stars every day you're not Dave Pacman
well okay uh but you can still listen to
the bonus show we are going to talk
about we we had this train derailment
even though train derailments have
actually been declining over the last
several decades we still have too many
we want to reduce the number great so
let's put together a bill to reduce
train derailments there is a bipartisan
rail safety bill that has been proposed
and it has hit a roadblock what is the
roadblock is it Bernie Sanders no
the roadblock is Republicans which you
probably could have guessed we will talk
about what's in the bill we will talk
about why Republicans are now getting in
the Bill's way secondly Gavin Newsom has
decided that California is not going to
do business with Walgreens over an
abortion pill issue what is the issue is
Gavin Newsom still thinking of running
for president or would he only do that
if Joe Biden doesn't run we're going to
talk about all of it on today's bonus
show and additionally
there is a lot of discussion about you
know if Trump doesn't win the Republican
nomination he'll run as an independent
and I think it would be great if he did
that and I think he could destroy the
Republican party if he did however there
are what are colloquially referred to as
sore loser laws in a handful of
important states that would not allow
Trump to run third party if he actually
stays in the Republican primary to the
end and loses it what is a sore loser
law we know Trump's a sore loser that
would that we don't need to explore but
what is a sore loser law how does it
work how could it affect Donald Trump's
ability
to run third party all of those stories
will be on today's bonus show you can
sign up at joinpakman.com we have a
coupon code that code is 24 starts now
you can also use the leftover from the
weekend code CPAC trash if you thought
like I did that CPAC was absolute trash
you can use the code CPAC trash to get a
discount also want to remind you we are
continuing to scale up the Spanish
Channel if you know of people who would
prefer to consume political content in
Spanish rather than English direct them
with total peace and love and generosity
to davidpackman.com Spanish we have
surpassed our first couple of thousand
subscribers on that channel I believe we
just have made some additional
improvements to the channel which are
really great make sure you are aware of
that and then lastly remember the best
things you can do to support our program
are all free make sure you're subscribed
to our podcast on any podcasting
platform you like Stitcher Pandora
Spotify iTunes Google
whatever make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel where we are pushing
towards 2 million subscribers all of
these things leave a comment leave a
like leave a review on iTunes these
things cost nothing
and they really do help Independent
Media I will see you on the bonus show
and we'll be back tomorrow with a brand
new show